people scheming over a senate seat Nancy
Pelosi's office now denying a report
that claims her daughter is helping out
ailing Democratic senator Dianne
Feinstein in order to help Nancy
Pelosi's buddy Adam Schiff win difi's
senate seat next year the nearly
nine-year-old Democrat Senator has been
facing intense pressure to resign amid a
flurry of serious health problems that
call into question her ability to serve
Pelosi's oldest daughter has been
spotted pushing feinsteiner out in a
wheelchair around the Capitol and
Politico says it's not a coincidence an
unnamed Pelosi family confidante is
quoted saying if difi resigns right now
there is an enormous probability that
Barbara Lee gets appointed thus it makes
it harder for Schiff team Pelosi is
wanting down the report with this very
concise response quote no but other
Democrats think it's time for Feinstein
to step aside
but it's sad for anyone to see and it's
sad for her own colleagues to see I'm
hopeful that people who are close to her
can talk to her and just say look end uh
your service with dignity step aside uh
let the governor appoint someone but now
it's just painful it's painful to watch
and my hope is I know there are people
who are close to her I don't think it
should be forceful I think they should
have a loving conversation about it
being time so Jessica I want to go to
you first about this push that they're
on to get Senator Feinstein out of her
seat it does seem like her health is in
very serious condition yeah but should
it be her choice and should it be the
voter's Choice as well in her primary
everybody should choose the same thing
here and whatever it takes to make
Dianne Feinstein Feinstein I always like
mess it up and I'm Jewish uh
understand the gravity of what's going
on is at first we thought it was just
shingles then we find out that it's also
Ramsay Hunt syndrome and Encephalitis
she's 89 years old she's been through a
lot her husband died a few years ago
which is an enormous change in her life
and I think that the people who are
making the arguments about this
Democrats are looking back at this
incredible career right
um from being the mayor of San Francisco
up to you know
the lead senator in the con in
California and saying don't go out like
this
there there is a better way and then
there's also the politics of it so
rokana well I agree with what he's
saying he's an ally of Barbara Lee's and
we know that Gavin Newsom has said that
he's going to appoint a black woman
two that's he when it becomes available
if he has the chance so that's going to
be Barbara Lee so it doesn't seem like
the purest of intentions there but Joe
Biden it's about federal judges Joe
Biden just confirmed his 129th federal
judge that's now ahead tracking out of
what Trump and Obama and George W bush
had been able to do by this point in
their presidency and when you look at
the makeup of the Supreme Court you know
how important then the federal bench is
and we can't if she goes again yeah no
one can vote in her place that's how
Lindsey Graham was able to make sure
that they took that two and a half
months off right so judge I mean they
say that they're concerned about her
dignity and leaving her career on a high
note I'm not sure that's true in
California Democratic politics and all
these people are fighting over the seat
but it seems like Nancy Pelosi is trying
to pay back Adam Schiff for taking on
President Trump impeaching him twice and
taking on that role and he wants the
state yeah Adam Schiff lied to the
American people a bold-faced lie I have
evidence Beyond a reasonable doubt that
Donald Trump was a you know Putin Ally
and a uh a Russian puppet and this is
all about Paul I think I don't know that
any state other than maybe New York is
as politicized as California is there's
like this family Dynamic with Feinstein
and Pelosi and Newsome who's whose aunt
that kind of thing and it's it doesn't
matter honestly you can call this is all
words you can say we want her to go out
on a high note you know low note the
woman has Encephalitis okay that's
that's an inflammation of the brain she
does not remember that she was in the
hospital for 3 three months I mean the
Press put it to her and she says no I've
been here I've been here voting no she
wasn't in for three months but you know
I just think and I want to take a second
to compare how the woman is like John
fetterman I mean they don't care it's
all about power when Trump was walking
down a ramp and I think this was in June
of 2020. he had just spoken I believe at
West Point and there was a slick metal
ramp with no uh handles no bars no
sidebars and he was hesitantly
descending down because he said it was
slippery he had no shoes on and
everybody says emerging of him gingerly
walking down a ramp hesitantly
descending down a ramp there are
questions as to whether or not he is
capable I mean you know the man is
healthy as hell and can't you know and
and it's but they turn it no let me
finish this woman is not healthy yeah
not a harder push right but they say
that Joe Biden can't do it he can't
stand up against lost in a crowd
the California senate seat um what
happens if Adam Schiff gets expelled
from Congress yeah unlikely but
resolution has been introduced to do
that
yeah I mean that would be the right
thing to do I don't think we're going to
get five Democrats to vote on that
unless they want him damaged from
getting the senate seat you know
Democrat politics can get very messy
especially when you have the Chicago
crowd playing around with that let's see
what Axelrod has to say about this
um but the judge hit on something that
should not be dismissed
it's the health and fitness of the
Democrat candidates and I'm so sick and
tired of them
pretending like we're The Crazy Ones
when we can see what's happening here
Dianne Feinstein two years ago there was
a report that came out that said that
she was reintroducing herself to her own
colleagues
two years ago and she's been you mean to
tell me she knows the votes that she's
been casted yeah where are all the
people talking about democracy we have
people that are unelected that are
telling the sitting senator from
California how to vote how's that
Democratic it's not you got betterment
the same thing and now all of this stuff
was discussed on the campaign Trail and
it was dismissed then you got Joe Biden
and you can tell by because and you know
we talked about oh I'm not a doctor you
know screw it okay everybody sees what
they see
he has good days and he has bad days and
you know that's how dementia patient's
working I don't know what he got but I
do know
I do know when he's having a good day
because the White House Wills him out
all of a sudden he's going to do a press
conference all of a sudden he doesn't
need his his cue cards with the pictures
of all the members of the press he's
having a good day no he always needs
that all right the other day when he did
that question he didn't have it he was
honest I don't know I don't know um I
don't know what he got yeah listen uh
there's a the reason why it looks like
Democrats are having a problem with
pushing elderly members out front is
because they're the only ones that have
any credibility to bring forward this
crazy agenda they have if you let AOC be
the spokesperson for the green New Deal
none of it ever passes because all the
tricks in her bag focus on being radical
and and over the top and asking for way
more than is reasonable and that's the
appeal to her but that specific policy
doesn't have a pill but if you let 40
years 50 years in service Uncle Joe
bring it out in a piece of policy if you
let Nancy Pelosi put it through the
house and a piece of policy there's a
certain amount of comfort and
credibility that that they believe comes
with it with their voters that have a
little bit of sanity left as those
people leave or die out who's going to
be left with credibility that's one
thing that Republicans have gotten right
and that we do bring in people that are
new I mean Trump wasn't in office until
he was President Ron DeSantis was not a
known commodity six years ago and so
they do have a problem with age but it's
more of a problem with their crazy
policies anyone know how old Chuck
Grassley is yeah
Chuck Grassley also runs like seven
miles a day anyway right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else